good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
my name is Lisa Lord apart from working
here at the University of Penn I also
lead a public speaking organization
called strictly speaking Toastmasters
that meets here at the Penn bookstore
I'd like to thank our gracious host
Kimberly berry for allowing us to meet
here and for inviting me to introduce
two phenomenal women authors appearing
here today a Jana Byrd is a writer and
editor living in Brooklyn New York
a Phi Beta Kappa graduate of Columbia
University's Barnard College she is an
entertainment journalist whose work has
appeared and vibe
Rolling Stone honey guy excuse me TV
Guide and paper magazines she has
appeared on a number of panels to
discuss the issue of gender class and
race and including appearing at
Harvard's Black Arts Festival
lore'l Tharp's is a graduate of Smith
College and received her master's degree
from Columbia University's Graduate
School of Journalism she also lives in
Brooklyn New York and isn't currently
employed as a correspondent for
Entertainment Weekly her work has
appeared in essence by Savoy and MS
magazines she is a contributor to the
upcoming anthology young wives tales new
adventures and love and partnership
together
Burt and thoughts have collaborated on a
unique new cultural history hair story
untangling the roots of black hair in
America
haier story explores the unique issue of
african-american hair and all of its
complexities
the authors delve into the history and
culture of black hair and explain how
something so seemingly superficial has
such far-reaching effects it profiles
major black hair icons such as madam CJ
Walker and net also known as the bush
doctor Malthus and it also includes
interviews with celebrities such as Tyra
Banks and Laura Lisa Bonet
stylish and cultural critics this book
examines the historically loaded terms
good and bad hair that exists within
black communities and it traces a unique
aspect of American history that people
of all races will enjoy as a reference
guide for celebrating and understanding
black hair as part of the pen author
series here at the pen bookstore please
join me in welcoming the authors a jana
Deibert and laurie
elf arts we'd like to start by getting
people involved in this discussion right
from the beginning and we had some
questions to ask and if you know the
answer just feel free to yell it out if
you want to raise your hand and makes
you comfortable you can raise your hand
but just if you know the answer just
shout it out umm what hairstyle was
Michael Jackson wearing in 1984 when it
caught on fire during the filming of the
Pepsi commercial
jheri-curl
yes that is correct what let's see what
hairstyle caused the United States
military several commercial airline
companies and hospitals across the
country to change their uniform
requirements yeah the Admiral that is
correct the Afro was in the when in the
60s when people started wearing the Afro
in such great numbers military hats
nurses hats they could not accommodate
that much hair so they had to actually
change the standard size of these hats
which might sound like a superficial
change but the fact that it made such a
impact that these government
organizations and private organizations
had to take note of something that black
people were collectively doing just as
one implication of the the power of
black hair and the last question is what
was the first black owned company to be
traded on the American Stock Exchange
it's Johnson products correct the Webb
makers of things like Johnson soft Sheen
relaxer the Johnson blue what is the
hair grease that's good Johnson agrees
the jar of blue stuff exactly so these
are some of the questions these are some
of the questions that we thought about
and were intrigued by that kind of got
us on this journey of hair and the way
this book started was two separate
projects I would nose when I was in
graduate school at Columbia I had to
choose a topic to write about for a
year-long thesis and I chose to do to do
it a paper on black hair on the politics
history and economics of black hair and
originally my advisor told me that that
wasn't a topic that there was no way I
could write a full year's a full year's
project on black hair she she was a
white woman from England who really just
had no
leave no idea that there could be
something something could be done of
that magnitude on here and I said well
I'm gonna do it anyway and she agreed to
let me try and when she saw the finished
product she was so impressed by all of
this information that she never known
about and she ended up taking my paper
and giving it to a friend who had just
adopted a black child was a white friend
who had adopted a black child she told
me that I should turn this into a book
and at the time I was just worrying
about finding a job so I really didn't
think about writing a book but it was in
the back of my mind that there was even
more just more to say and I graduated in
1997 and started working at vibe
magazine where I met Iona and in 1993 I
was at Barnard College and had to do a
sociology paper for a class on American
popular culture and decided I was gonna
do something on black women and beauty
images but the night before the paper
was due all I had were my three black
roommates to interview for the paper and
I I'd since I start talking to them and
all of their issues that kept coming up
or about hair and so I decided well that
was even easier to just write about hair
because there's a narrower topic and it
was also something I had been very
interested in I had cut all of my hair
off to about this long the year before
and I'd done it because I thought it
would be easy and I got in the rain and
I'd have to worry about I can go to the
gym and really it impacted me in ways
that I hadn't thought it would when I
first cut it off it impacted my
self-esteem it made me think like oh
boys aren't going to talk to me and all
these different things that I did not
think would come up over haircut and so
a lot of these women I thought I was
crazy when I had all of these thoughts
and concerns and worries a year before I
did my paper but the women that I spoke
to also said a lot of the same things
and I realized it you know it was a
topic that wasn't just me being
obsessive and dramatic and so I did this
paper and my professor was kind of like
oh black hair great there was a white
man who really thought I was just crazy
to try to you know cram ten pages worth
of anything about hair but when it was
over the same was Laurie he thought it
was wonderful and he zero accident he
took it to a conference and oh you have
to write a book and I was like
I just have to you know graduate and
then the next year I had to do an
honours project and I decided to do a
collection of essays on hair and I
looked at black women and my paper
unlike laureates was more sociological
and we met that vibe as she said in 1997
and realized we've both done these
projects on hair with professors who had
initially thought you know is that even
a topic who ended up telling us to do a
book and so we figured okay well we'll
do a book and it took us about another
year to really decide to write the book
and and so we did excuse me besides
besides the the ideas that we had
formulated in these years or our own
personal projects we had also just had
so much reinforcement by black people in
this country who had so many common
experiences feelings interactions when
the workplace at school at summer camp
where we said all of these commonalities
need to be documented there has to be a
reason that black people can talk to one
another perfect strangers go up to one
another and say did this ever happen to
you or how did you do this to your hair
and there's a there's an instant
recognition there's an instant bond
there so we thought there's something
there that should be written down and
also there are so many times that non
black people were curious about black
hair they had questions and they didn't
even know how to state the question they
would want to know how did you do that
to your hair why do black people you
know get so concerned about rain or or
you know how come how come my coworker
had short hair yesterday and today it's
down to her back and you know why you
know all these questions and we thought
again there needs to be something that
non black people who do have questions
and maybe don't want to go and be
obnoxious or rude or seem to be
uneducated about black people can also
just pick up a book and say oh I
understand it's more than just it's more
than just hair there is something to be
said there is a history there and and
that's also what we wanted to do with
this book
and finally it was important for us to
write a book that just documented
chronologically just the history behind
the hair we did not what we're not
qualified to do any kind of how-to
haircare book and which I think a lot of
people assume that that's what it is
it's not we also felt like it was really
important to do a book that did not
necessarily state our personal opinions
and actually as we wrote the book I
think my opinions about hair changed a
lot but we just wanted to state the
different aesthetic political economic
meanings that our hair has always had
and it definitely includes the opinions
of a lot of different people but not
necessarily of of us and us a lot of
times when people look at us and assume
oh well they have dreadlocks they must
think that if you have straight hair it
means X Y & Z and if you have natural
hair means your consciousness is you
know whatever and and we did not want
that to come across in the book because
I look there's my grandmother sorry
because we felt like the history of our
hair is so rich and it's not just about
the struggles and it's not just about oh
should you wear your hair natural should
you wear it straight it's also just
celebrating all the different looks that
we've had and the artistry behind it so
with that we are going to start reading
a few selections from it I know most
people are here for lunch so we're going
to keep it really short
okay as we stated the the book is
chronological it starts in Africa and
the 1400s and goes all the way to today
chapter by chapter we go through a
different period of history and
obviously the first place we have to
begin is in Africa before the people who
are we consider black Americans now were
in the West African countries so excuse
me the story starts in Africa black hair
and bondage 1,400 through 1899 the story
of black people's hair begins where
everything began in Africa not
surprisingly the birthplace of both
astronomy and alchemy also gave rise to
a people in perfect harmony with their
environment
indeed the dense spiralling curls of
African hair demonstrate evolutionary
genius like natural air conditioning
this frizzy kinky hair insulates the
head from the brutal intensity of the
sun's rays of course there's not one
single type of African hair just as
there's not one single type of African
the variety of hair textures from
western Africa alone ranges from the
deep evany kinky curls of Vending goes
to the loosely curled flowing locks of
the Ashanti the one constant Africans
share when it comes to hair is the
social and cultural significance
intrinsic to each beautiful strand in
the early 15th century hair function as
a carrier of messages in most West
African societies the citizens of these
societies including the Wallace Mende
mending go Yoruba were the people who
filled the slave ships that sailed to
the New World
within these cultures hair was an
integral part of a complex language
system ever since African civilizations
bloomed hairstyles have been used to
indicate a person's marital status age
religion ethnic identity wealth and rank
within the community the rest of the
chapter goes on to explain how important
the hairstyle was to the individual
African it was really there we said
earlier this morning that was almost
like your social security number because
it wasn't just your name it was
everything
about you could be ascertained just by
looking at your hair I could look at
somebody and say oh I know your name is
Jan Smith and that you work here and
this is the profession you're in and
you're at this level of society and also
that the hair was also had spiritual
connotations to a person's spirit was
connected to the hair therefore anybody
who was a hairdresser also had a very
elevated place in society because you
know you would not trust just anybody to
touch this pressured this precious
possession you had and then when the
Africans were captured by slave traders
one of the first things that the slave
traders did was shave off the hair
probably just as a hygiene thing but in
essence what they were doing was cutting
off their identity I mean it was really
just stripping them of who they were and
then in slavery you had you had a
lifestyle which clearly was not
conducive to maintaining these elaborate
beautiful hairstyles and on top of that
those the stress the poor nutrition and
just the the degrading lifestyle was
really detrimental to anybody keeping up
something like the hairstyles that were
done in Africa and on top of that was
the kind of I don't want to say
brainwashing exactly but the kind of the
the the white okay we could call it
brainwashing V the slave owners would
tell the slaves that their hair was
inferior that it would they would even
classify it as wool to suggest that the
blacks were more animalistic and if they
were animals they were easier to keep as
slaves because if they thought
themselves as inferior it was easier to
keep them you know under their control
so this was what happened and then you
had blacks instead of trying to make the
elaborate hairstyles of Africa they were
more in trying to straighten the hair
and make it look more European and
that's where the transition really
happened from loving and adorning the
hair in the traditional African sense to
trying to make the hair fit into a
European standard so that's what chapter
one is and that's why it's called black
hair and bondage so we're going to skip
to a section
we have an entire chapter on the afro
and Lori and I were born at the well in
the early 70s as the afro was it was
still around that it was losing its hold
and we both assumed it was rewriting
this book that oh you know everybody
loved the after everybody wore an afro I
look at old pictures of my family they
all had afros but as we learned while we
were writing this that was not the case
at all and this hairstyle also while it
started with very political roots behind
it no pun intended um it it definitely
really transitions into more of a
fashion statement so the opening of that
chapter and chapters called
revolutionary roots Naturals afros and
the changing politics of hair 1965 to
1979 in 1964 Philadelphia artist Samuel
Roosevelt was an eighteen-year-old Air
Force airman first class stationed in
the Philippines and he had a problem
after a number of fruitless searches and
some unfortunate haircuts Roosevelt was
unable to find a good barber the
solution was simply to let his hair grow
upon release from the military in 1966
Roosevelt and his uncut hair returned
home to Philadelphia where he was
promptly made fun of by friends and
family they told me that I looked a mess
and needed to go and do my hair
Roosevelt recalls then less than a year
later they're running around afro picks
trying to get their fros higher and
acting like this was how they had always
looked all of their lives between 1964
and 1966 color people and Negroes became
black people and these black people
overwhelmingly chose to adopt a new
black identified visual aesthetic an
aesthetic that not only incorporated an
alternative to straight hair but
actually celebrated it in the mid 60s
black hair underwent its biggest change
since Africans arrived in America the
very perception of hair shifted from one
of styled to statement and right or
wrong blacks and whites came to believe
that the way black people wore their
hair said something about their politics
hair can symbolize either continued move
toward integration in the American
political system or a growing cry for
black power nationalism many African
Americans began to use their hair as a
way to show a visible connection to
their African ancestors and blacks
throughout the Diaspora it was an errand
which hair took a prime spot right next
to placards amendments and marches and
defining a black identity
the world at large and I think some
twenty thirty years after the after
looking back on it and its significance
I think the two most important things
about it was that one it was the first
time that black people collectively
showed that they you know this this was
not this but you know an afro was what
their hair really looked like underneath
the perms and the straightening combs
and wigs and all the other things that
we were doing it was also important
because it was the first time that hair
was a political statement that we were
consciously making whereas today I think
a lot of times we do things to our hair
because we we like it whether it's
straight hair or braids or weave or
whatever we do a lot of times we assume
you know I'm just doing this because
this is how I like my hair but other
people are still reading all these
political things onto it and and it
definitely I think began with the afro
in the last section excuse me the last
section we're going to read is from the
80s the beginning of the eighties
chapter which we call politically
incorrect black hairs new attitude and
this is from transitioning from the afro
where the hair was so political and so
meaningful to a point where the hair
became devoid of any political meaning
and it really became a matter of of
style and it was almost as if people
were were trying to put the afro as far
behind him as possible and doing
straight styles and if you remember
patty LaBelle's she kind of stands out
as a prime example
you always were wondering how high her
wings were gonna go but she just kind of
stands out at that time that's what
people were we're really just going for
it kitten felt it fit fit with the
decade of the me decade of the
Reaganomics and everything else that
kind of symbolized excess in the 80s but
the interesting thing was that the the
decade started 1979 with the movie ten
and a woman named Bo Derek who made a
big splash in the black hair community
with cornrows excuse me
in 1979 Bo Derek made the movie ten in
it she wore her hair in cornrows with
beads on the end the same style that
Cicely Tyson had worn more than a decade
earlier by 1980 on the pages of Time and
Newsweek and in the lexicon of the
population at large partners had come to
be known as Bo braids even those
mainstream publications that took the
time to note the African roots of the
style seldom included photos of black
women wearing them someone some like to
point to Bo Derek as an example of
Americans Americas embracing a
multicultural more inclusive beauty
ideal the response was not favorable on
all fronts however the african-american
community and black women in particular
saw it is adding insult to injury quote
I saw danger in Bo Derek remembers MS
magazines Marsha Gillespie what I would
offended me was that it was bad enough
that they were going to tell me that she
was the most beautiful woman in the
world but then to put her in cornrows as
if to cover all the bases after years of
being seen as the anti Beauty black
women now had to face something that was
essentially stripped of its historical
legacy and only given a claim after
being adopted by a white blond woman in
an interview shortly after tens release
Roberta Flack who had been wearing her
natural hair braided for some time
expressed her anger quote black women
were wearing cornrows long before Bo
Derrick unquote she told the Christian
Science Monitor I took issue that
White's made such a big thing about Bo
Derek and cornrows I can see this both
derrick dial going out the $10 with
braids and they'll make a million
zillion dollars off of it
unquote in a Jet magazine article
headline on a scale of one to ten blacks
are black straight angry over Bo Derek's
hairdo fad stylist celebrities and other
black women and men echoed flak
statements blacks overwhelmingly felt as
though a cultural legacy had been
literally whitewashed
so that just kind of goes to the the the
question that we are often asked is
here political is it still political and
people always want to think of political
hit black hair being political it's just
the 60s you know the afro that was the
political time and it just stopped being
political and this is just another
example is when when we have we talk
about cultural misappropriation when we
talk about black people wearing our
black people straightening their hair
and trying to look white white or non
black people wearing traditionally black
styles we even in this chapter we talked
about dreadlocks as well and we get into
kind of can black people co-opted a
style that's not black Americans that
style wasn't that black American style
it was more of a traditionally Jamaican
style and it's not even Jamaican
necessarily there's roots of dreadlocks
in Asian societies from centuries ago so
this was when we when the discussion of
black hair being political it covers so
many different realms and and this is
where a lot of times non black people
don't understand why it can be
considered so political when we talk
about the business of black hair we do a
chapter on that as well and a lot of
major manufacturers non black ones they
make bids to purchase companies and
don't understand the out roar the the
the way that the black community will
respond when a white company makes a bid
to buy a black company because it's not
it's never been just hair even in the
business of black hair which is a
multi-billion dollar industry today and
it has always been a very thriving
business and and there always has to be
explanations why hair is political so
the rest of the book after the eighties
chapter we talked about we have a
separate chapter called the culture of
black hair where we try to explain what
it means to live in America with black
hair we talk about the language of black
hair we talk about the rights in which
rites and rituals of growing up with
black hair the technology the tools all
of these things that if you are a black
person in America you probably
understand what we're talking about or
if you have access to the black
community you also know what we're
talking about but if you don't which is
a
lot of the rest of America you have no
idea what we're talking about and that's
why we tried to write it down and
explain it and in the last chapter we
kind of do a state of where we are today
with black hair in America testimonials
in the back so I went through that phase
when the hair was a big issue did you
interview military personnel because
just recently did the military change
its documents on how black hair could be
worn because during up the desert storm
it was more practical for women to wear
their hair braided however they got in a
lot of trouble because it wasn't in
regulations that it was authorized and a
lot of women were punished really and
then they were like white first
sergeant's that would say to women I
find your hair offensive no no we didn't
I'm learning about this we talked to a
couple from the 60s when they were
coming out of the military more people
who had always kept their hair short and
kept their hair in military style cuts
and then when the sixth when they came
out they were so surprised and and even
shocked themselves one man we
interviewed in the Midwest he was in the
Navy and he remembers seeing the Afro
and he had been indoctrinated if you
will to believe that that was a good
hair style you know keep it short and
when he saw that afro he he with all his
military training he was really like
that's a bad thing it's a horrible thing
it's not right to have your hair looking
that crazy so those are the military
people we spoke to we're more from the
pack were more 60s yeah I like to know
how you would classify the hairstyles
today in particular of the young crowd I
think it's very unique and someone else
coming from the old school I think
doesn't understand it black or not black
I think I think you have to be really
careful answering that because it's so
regional living in New York I think I
have a definite idea that Oh everyone's
just kind of doing whatever with their
hair and
they'll have you know a long leave on
Monday and they'll have dread extensions
by Friday and it means the same thing to
them but then whenever we travel or I
just talked to people from other parts
of the country I realized that's not
necessarily the case young people I
think have always been the most creative
and daring and what they'll do with
their hair and a lot of that is first
I'll they have a lot of time and they
don't necessarily have to get a job
someone's supporting them so they don't
have to really worry about how their
hair is gonna be read um I think today
more and more people are there's
definitely way more natural styles and
they're also a lot of them you can get
dread extensions you can get an afro
weave you can get so like they're all
these combinations of things whereas in
the past if you had an afro you weren't
even thinking about getting a weave and
it meant two totally different things
and now people are mixing those things
up and you have women who are wearing
straight hair and wigs and it's not a
secret they're like yeah you know my
hair is pink in here today and it's
short pixie blonde cut the next day and
and it's but I think hair is a lot more
fun I think that we have a lot we have
not a lot we have more public figures
who wear our diversity of hairstyles
than we ever have in the past I mean
there's still definitely way more women
with long straight hair in the public
but you know there's even Halle Berry
with her short cut and Lisa Bonet and
Lauryn Hill and even min Maxwell
D'Angelo I mean Allen Iverson there's
there's a lot more diversity I think the
prep not the problem I think the issue
today is that people are doing things
just for fun or just because I like it
but then my step-brother had cornrows
for a while and he had a hard time
getting a job after school straight I
mean not straight a su mean I was a good
student he's a good kid but people
thought he looked like a thug I've had
conversations with members of my family
who used to wear afros and who you know
follow the Black Power movement who
today are like oh you know I I don't
know if I would hire a guy with cornrows
because they look thuggish I'm like what
are you talking about like it's talked
to him see if he's thuggish like how are
you just gonna write him off because of
his hairstyle especially if you're a
child of the 60s and you're saying that
but it definitely happens and that's
reality and I think today we need to be
aware of the fact that yeah you might
decide
to wear a wig that is you know
multicolored and all these things and
it's just how you want to look that day
but you have to understand other people
are deciding all these other things
about you classify some of the radical
hairstyles like I can't think of his
name sometimes when they wear the plat
sticking out straight out to the side
you wouldn't classify that as a
political statement are you saying my
best around what's the rhyme I don't
think they're well with Busta Rhymes I
don't think he's I mean he's he's in
celebrity so I think the things that
they do are not necessarily mean I don't
think anyone's asking Gwen Stefani if
she's like relating to the punk movement
because her hair is pink and you know
doing these different things I think
celebrities kind of do what they decide
to do unless they really to get
attention and because they can because
they're there their livelihood it
actually will probably be helped along
if they look different from everyone
else um but no I don't think I don't
think a Busta Rhymes is making a
political statement with his hair and I
think if anything he's probably opening
the door a little more especially now
that he's making movies and he's way
more mainstream than he wasn't we
started out in his career forced someone
who decides to wear dreads maybe to have
like one less hurdle to cross when
they're going in front of a white person
for a job or in front of a black person
who thinks styles like that are radical
that hide the hair completely there's it
historically it's interesting because a
lot of in slavery we know that a lot of
black women wore kerchiefs and people
assumed that that's of that is something
that black people have historically
always done when in fact in our research
we found that it was because the hair
was so glorified in Africa covering it
was something that people did not do I
mean it was not something you wouldn't
cover your hair it was so it was your
identifier so you would not put
something on it and in slavery people
covered it more out of shame or just
because they didn't have time to excuse
me they didn't have time to to do
something to it so today it's
interesting when you see people saying
they're reclaiming their African
heritage by wearing a kerchief that's
not really true although there are other
African nations where you do you have
head wraps and things like that but
that's again it's just a type of I think
black Americans ability to be creative
and expressive and of course you see
young people today boys boys and girls
wearing bandanas head scarves and again
I think that just points to our
creativity and in incorporating
different looks and you look at
celebrities too I mean something like
Arabic Erykah Badu who took her bandanna
to the 10th extreme but still that kind
of led the way for people to you know
make it shorter or smaller but still the
idea that you know we can incorporate
head wraps with beautiful cloth
beautiful colors and for men who don't
want to go all that way but still they
too can incorporate that look into their
into their fashion sense I think it's a
question back there
you know from what I understand there is
a tradition of wrapping the head in West
Africa and that just the style of rap
also went along with the hair indicates
a certain status marital status that
there's specific ways in which you rap
which means certain things but first of
all I just wanted to tell you both that
you're beautiful and second before I run
out I just had a quick question you
talked about the 80s and I mean I was
born in 72 and we might be around you
know computers I remember you know just
growing up in the 80s and a symmetrical
cuts and all that other stuff that we
used to do and you contextualize the 80s
very well in terms of history and I
wondered kind of like with with the
question that this woman asked here in
terms of the 90s and the weaves and the
wigs do you see that historically is
just kind of going back to the 60s where
we wore wigs and it's just kind of
coming back around or do you see that
more in terms of the culture of the late
90s and what that you know may what what
values that might be connected to that
just as the 80s you said it was kind of
coming from the XS and the Dada Dada I
wondered if you kind of could comment on
the Whigs and the weeds now as opposed
to how they may have been at another
point in our history I think the it's
interesting and it's this is why this
writing this book was so interesting was
to see the historical continuum because
people were wearing wigs black male
slaves are wearing wigs in the 1700s in
emulation of the slave masters who also
wore wigs in the 50s women wore wigs
because they couldn't get the long
straight styles that were in fashion
black or white both were wearing wigs in
the 20s actually women who had managed
to grow really long hair when the
flapper styles came in start wearing
short wigs because they refused to cut
their hair but you know they wanted to
look so then in the 80s when weaves
became very popular the idea was you can
wear a weave and get that long hair and
not let anyone know that you're wearing
a weave there was definitely a secrecy
about wearing a weave or a wig you
didn't tell anybody
whereas in the 90s and today you have
people wearing wigs and weaves but
they're a lot more upfront about it you
don't get the kind of you have to do it
you know two o'clock in the morning and
appear for a week and come back and and
hope no one notices that your hair just
grow and that's I think the difference
that we're seeing today versus ten years
ago um you have celebrities also which
celebrities really accept fashion trends
a lot for us and when you have a
celebrity like Tyra Banks who you know
we talked to for this book who can go on
Oprah or go anywhere and and say quite
freely yeah this is a weave and I wear a
weave because it's easier for me to you
know get different styles as a model
it's you know it's too much work on my
hair to be switching styles and trying
to curl it one day and do this into the
other thing it's a weave and you took
enough hair like Tyra I'll tell you the
kind I use Toni Braxton's same thing
whereas essentially there's this
openness about it now and person like
little Kim who can wear a long wig that
nobody believes that that is her hair
it's platinum blonde or pink or orange
and so it's like yes I'm faking it but
it just goes with what I'm wearing today
and that again I think shows a
development of acceptability within the
black community and a kind of we don't
care what anyone else says this looks
good on me today I'm gonna try it and
again because you can see it on
television on anything from a sprite
commercial to a video these things are
more acceptable and people can step out
of the house and not have the like fear
that oh I'm wearing a weave that means
something about me or anything no it
means that somebody else was wearing it
yesterday look good and I think it'll
look good on me too
but I also don't want to oversimplify
that I think too much well I think
there's still a huge idea of if I don't
have straight hair I'm not attractive if
I don't have long hair I'm not
attractive I mean it's it's definitely I
think lessening but and I think a lot of
us because you know our generation I was
born in 73 we were raised by parents
whatever their hair looks like now they
probably had an afro or their best
friend did or they knew about them and
so it was an idea to us that you know
you didn't have to straighten your hair
even if they now have straight hair but
so it Laurie said I think is true that a
lot of times women more and more like
well it's just because I like it this
way but I think the question that a lot
of us still have
to ask ourselves is okay but could you
also like it if it was that long and
natural and that's where we still are
we're know for most people and it's not
just oh my face wouldn't look good with
this it's that we really think it would
tie up so much of who we are to get rid
of our hair kind of troubling that it's
no longer secretive not that it was good
to be secretive but it's just like yes I
mean this is a wig and this is a wig
it's like but when you put on a wig how
are you nurturing your own hair I mean
your own hair is under there and it's
like you're not it's not breathing I
don't know I don't know how well you're
maintaining and caring for your own hair
when you wear a wig all the time and I
guess that's a question you know what
are the things we just wanted to sing in
writing the book we weren't trying to
say you should not have straight hair
everybody should cut their hair off and
find their true inner self that's not
what we're trying to say but if we if
people understood the history of their
hair the power of their hair and what
their hair can do naturally you still
might choose to keep your hair straight
I mean it might you might like it better
that way but to be informed and to know
that's what I think the main goal is to
understand where not haircare
professionals we're not telling you how
to do your hair but if we did have one
aspect of that it was just it would just
be that you understood the history of
your hair before you you know said oh I
have to keep my hair like this because
you know it's not pretty the other way
it doesn't work the other way I don't I
won't be accepted the other way if I
think both of us in doing our own
projects I cut my hair off after finding
out the history of my hair just because
I wanted to see what did this this
product this thing that has brought us
through so much feel like and and again
it's still a choice I could still decide
it straighten my hair tomorrow but it
would be with an informed understanding
of what my hair has been through because
it does have its own history
to include or who did you decide to
interview how did you make that decision
in terms when you say there was Lisa
Bonet and other people that you had
interviewed so I wanted to know a little
bit about the process in that then you
mentioned some really interesting facts
about blacks and 18-something wearing
wigs how did you find that body of
research was there a lot of it or did
you have to sort of like dig and dig and
dig to find facts and to find this
information the answer to your first
question when we first decided to do the
book I mean had a proposal live we want
to travel here we want to talk to these
people as any first-time author would
probably tell you it was really it was
really reaching like we were going
everywhere we're going to Brazil we're
gonna Paris we're going to Senegal or
going all over the place I'm like our
little advance and and we also had this
huge list of people that we went to talk
to I think just because we've both done
projects on hair before and it was just
something we were interested in and just
living in this you know culture we we
knew people like I knew that Oprah once
had made the statement on a show about
always wanting hair that moves so I want
to talk about - Oprah about that
statement and we wanted to talk to
little Kim because her hair is just so
outrageous we wanted to talk to Lisa
Bonet because she's oh she's always had
these during the 80s while most people I
mean she had weaves
for a while and like the different world
time but she also always had these [ __ ]
like Nubian twit those knots for a while
on her like a couple of episodes and she
had short hair and she had dread
extensions this is before a lot of
people were experimenting with lots of
natural styles we wanted to talk to
Lauren because of her dreads want to
talk to Eric about do a tall these
people want to talk to well Oprah
doesn't talk to most people because she
especially now with her book club she
doesn't really want to seem like she's
endorsing any one project so we took
Oprah off the list and Lil Kim was
making albums so we took her off the
list
so the celebrities it came down to we
definitely want to talk to a model and
Tyra Banks has made so many statements
about her hair over the past and wearing
leaves that we just made an effort to
get in touch with certain people that we
felt we just needed as key people um
there are also certain academics
with bell hooks we've interviewed we
talked to Kerala via Iran who wrote this
children's book called
nappy hair which caused this huge uproar
in Brooklyn and 98 and and then we just
wanted to talk to a lot of people on the
street so the internet was actually a
really great tool for us we had this
like it wasn't a survey which is kind of
a questionnaire on hair and we sent it
out to you know just people we knew I
really please forward this and every
time I came back to my desk I had like
30 new emails we had no idea
luckily Laurie was writing the chapter
that included all of those things so
every day she's like more for you Laurie
and reported them to her but that was
really amazing Ann you know every so
often one of those emails would be from
somebody pointing out oh actually you
should talk to this person they just did
a study on whatever and we also did
focus groups around the country looked
through photographs of our family
members for ideas yeah so that was how
it came up and you know as we were
reading anything that someone else maybe
had quoted somewhere we would just try
to find that person and talk to them and
then your other question about finding
out information about wigs in the 1800
Xers of 1700 18th century 1700s that was
the hardest part of doing this research
in that this book has never been written
before nobody has taken well maybe they
tried to and couldn't put it together
for whatever reason but there wasn't a
document there wasn't one body of work
that said this is what black people have
been doing with their hair since the
beginning of time so we had to do things
we basically went to first-person
sources we looked at European explorers
travel logs and their diary descriptions
of what Africans were doing with their
hair we looked at runaway slave posters
that described in detail you know slave
missing looks like this you know has
hair like this where's their hair like
this the things about the wigs that was
mentioned in the runaway slave posters
wears wears a wig often seen in a wig
trying to emulate his master or
something like that so we really did
look at just documents that were from
those times we did a lot we spent a lot
of
I'm in research libraries looking at
also in newspapers black newspapers that
also would describe these styles what
people should wear or shouldn't wear
what was fashionable for the time so it
was right the slave interviews were very
instrumental in saying no this is what
people were wearing this is why they
were wearing it and it wasn't it was
better that way actually because it
wasn't it was a very it wasn't
subjective in any way it was just
description so that's what we had to do
is pull from there make inferences and
then talk to historians who could say
yes this is what people were doing this
makes sense for that time research did
you find that black men in the corporate
world didn't have the freedom or that
black women because I find that I I know
in particular their black men here that
have graduated from law school or
medical school and some of them had
dreads and they couldn't get a job and
when I saw them again they said I had to
cut my hair in order to get a job I
think the fight over how to wear your
hair in the workplace start it with
black women in the late 70s and early
80s when we started wearing cornrows a
lot and women of every class level were
wearing their hair braided or cornrows
and there was a huge class-action suit
taken against the Hyatt Hotels from
about a thousand women in in the
Washington DC area who had been
suspended or fired from their jobs for
wearing braids there were a lot of
individual court cases mostly from
flight attendants hotel recept front
front desk people who were getting in
you know who were getting in trouble
over their hairstyles and the EEOC
actually in a lot of those cases they
went in favor of the women saying that
their hairstyle was part of their
culture it was a cultural legacy and
they should be allowed to wear it as
long as it was neat and presentable
which of course gets into other issues
of you know who's going to decide what's
eaten presentable but
open the door for women to have a lot
more choices I think of what they could
wear their hair like even though we
still today earlier we did a radio show
and a woman called in and she wants to
cut her hair she's straight relaxed hair
now and she wants to cut it to a natural
and eventually grow drug lab so she
works in a very corporate culture and
she's nervous about how that's going to
be taken but men today
I think face a lot more problems than
women with dirt with dreadlocks not just
in corporate settings but also in the
service industry messengers bank tellers
who are interfacing right and they're
actually a number of lawsuits that men
have brought out now and it goes back to
what I was saying earlier about how I
think for most of these men if you ask
them they probably they like dreads they
and the reasons might have be a mixture
of just no aesthetic choice with
cultural choices but they probably
weren't trying to take on you know their
their employer whatsoever when they mate
they weren't making a big statement they
were doing what they thought was
attractive for their hair and and yet
they're still faced with all these
issues that I think a lot of us thought
you know maybe we'd move past yes with a
book that probably shocked you the most
in your research and I do agree with you
that a lot of times you do make those
hair decisions on where you are working
it with your at your employer because I
remember when I used to work in the
corporate world I came with not braids
when I got comfortable enough there and
established myself I put my hair in
braids I remember the night that when I
came to Penn for an interview because I
did not know who was interviewing me and
what their thoughts might be about me I
just got my hair braided stood up all
night long I had girlfriends come over
took the whole braiding hairstyle out
because I wasn't sure who was going to
interview me and whether or not my
braids were going to impact their
decision I'm sorry with your research
what was it that you that either
reversed a belief or an assumption that
you had about black hair that you
learned that was totally just
I think for me the most the part that
was so amazing to me was the business
the chapter that we did on the business
of black hair
I was think I wrote in the I wrote in
the chapter it was kind of sarcastic of
me but I wrote not every black person
was a slave picking cotton in the south
during slavery because we found that
there were many many many black men and
women in some cases more men than women
but who were able to prosper during
slavery by being barbers and they were
barbers for white people they were the
black barbers were the ones who were
leading the field of blacks and white in
terms of being the most innovative and
offering the best services in salon
services for men and women and in fact
it was black men from the islands who
were the most sought-after hairstylist
because they the islands were mostly
European owned so they were considered
to have you know the they were supposed
to be the best knowing the most about
European fashion and style and since all
the Americans you know the American
colonists they want it to be as fashion
as the Europeans they're like get me one
of those men from you know the French
West Indies I want him to do my hair and
they made enough money
these black barbers some of them were
slaves would work enough to buy their
own freedom and then buy the freedom of
their loved ones their family members or
by their own slaves if they wanted to -
black barbers were the founders of the
first black University Wilberforce
University was founded by the funds of
two black barbers so to me finding out
that hair grant didn't was doing white
hair but still black people in the hair
industry during slavery were able to
build just but to start this legacy this
foundation and to pour money back into
the black community that to me is
incredible and that they were able to
hold on to this hold on to this business
until today where we have about a
multibillion-dollar it's about a 12
billion dollar industry today to me that
blew my mind I didn't realize the
economic power of black hair and that it
started in this country as soon as black
people got here
well officially they were indentured
servants but they were squiggly made
into slaves after about 50 years your oh
my let's see I think the biggest thing
for me was actually it just changed my
my own opinions on different hairstyles
that I maybe see every day on the street
around the subway I used to always judge
a hairstyle by would I do it to my own
hair there's a whole lot of things I
would not do to my own hair so I didn't
really appreciate them alright that's
crazy how could they got the house
looking like that and over the course of
and I I didn't want to put that idea
into the book but I had it and as I did
more research as I read because Laurie
and I split up writing the chapters as I
read her chapters and as I was
researching my own I just came to have
such an appreciation for our hair and
not just in its natural state but just
the artistic things that we do with it
and you know some of the most artistic
works of art are our straightened
hairstyles like the things that you've
seen hair shows and this year like the
woman who won I mean the style that won
the big hair show in Detroit was a
helicopter I mean no one's walking down
the street with their hair in a
helicopter but it's still you know it's
but for me it was just learning to
accept and have such an appreciation for
all of the different things that we do
with our hair and someone asked us once
you know who do you think our great has
great hair and one of the women I said
was a little Kim and she kind of looked
at me shocked because I think she
expected me to just run off a list of
every natural hair person in the public
eye and and I I love little Kim's hair
look I love all the daring things that
she will do with it I love that she does
not try to act like it's really her hair
and and that it's fun would I ever do
that no but so for me that was just
having the appreciation for our hair not
only so that you can make informed
choice about what you do yourself but
just to appreciate you know what other
people are doing and also one small
thing that I learned is that Madame CJ
Walker did not invent the hot comb which
Laurie knew
learned that from her master's thesis
but I didn't know that and the fact that
she's everyone knows her name and people
either know her as the first self-made
female millionaire in the United States
or and/or they condemn her for oh and
she gave us a straightening comb and I'm
like actually she didn't I mean she
introduced it to black America but you
know it had been around and if someone
else had just picked up they she doesn't
Roebuck catalog that it was available in
and noticed that it probably worked for
right here
you know they would have done it so so
those were two things that I got from it
and how are we on time actually how are
we on time so if I if I did I'm sorry
but did you talk in your book do you
talk about the politics of hair within
the within the group that's something
that we wanted to a lot of people assume
that that the issues about black hair
it's all black people facing white
America and if white America just
understood our hair we'd be happier
healthier people but when we found in
our most of our interviews with everyday
people was that many of the most
divisive situations about hair come
within the black community when we're
talking we talked about this on our
radio show this morning that black
people will say you know our parents or
our grandparents will say don't do that
to your hair
you will not get a job it looks bad we
worked so hard to not have to look like
that please don't do that
you used to be cute you know all of
these things that come from within the
black community and also again from
historically it started with black
companies even saying the barber so he
was just speaking about the black
barbers who were who were excelling
during slavery couldn't do black hair
they couldn't do the hair of their own
brethren if you will in the toy
you know think this is the I'm giving
you very obvious examples but you know
women who wanted to be dancers at
certain nightclubs in Harlem if your
hair wasn't a certain straightness you
couldn't work there churches would say
you can't come into our church if your
hair doesn't pass the comb test we found
anecdotal evidence of combs being hung
on the front door of a church and if
your hair couldn't pass through this
fine-tooth comb you couldn't be a member
of that church actually Philadelphia
churches
so yes the politics of black hair within
the black community I think would
probably astound most non black people
because again the politics come from
within our community of from history
historically saying the you will be a
you will get a head if you look like
this you will be left behind if your
hair looks like this and whether it's
people championing that because they
just care about you and want you to be
able to get ahead or people really and
really taking that to heart and saying
you are no good if your hair looks like
that
it really does come I think from within
the black community so that's not to say
that non black people don't have their
own issues or Mis beliefs or
miscommunication sections about hair but
I think the political real the real
arguments and divisive 'no scums from
within and again which is why we want
everybody to read our book then give it
to your grandmother and have her read it
to
one of the reasons that that people
outside of our community view our hair
politically is simply because we don't
understand it and we don't respect it
and we don't bring to it the kind of
ethnic understanding of who it is and
what it is so what it does is it gives
the larger community the ability to feed
into whatever they want to feed into
sure and so that's never going to change
until we change that's I agree I'm sorry
no no like thank you put it very well I
think this one gentleman right there had
one last question do you think that
because sometimes you know you might do
research you just say okay well let's
put most of the information in the first
book would you do another book or are
you thinking about doing it a lot more
information that we could include
especially in the last chapter well you
know I mean just speaking to you right
now that's a whole nother thing that we
did not about the military we didn't go
into that right that's huge when we were
writing there's one chapter on the cult
just on the culture of black hair and
just the issues about dating with black
hair that could be an entire book the
last chapter we really try to sum up
everything that was going on but we
really did not give as much space to
certain the book is just about America
and that was pretty easy to just write
about black Americans and keep it this
very monolithic group throughout most of
the book until you get to you know the
80s and the 90s especially in places
like New York where there's a lot of
West Indian immigration and the hair
issues like those two groups against
each other and common issues and and we
don't really go into that so there's
definitely more for another book will
there be another book I don't know
Lori's having a baby and I'm taking a
break and and so but we also think we
got a lot of comments from Hispanic
people who were so they're so connected
to a lot of these issues and they say
they have the same terms pelo bueno and
pelo Malo with you know good hair bad
hair that they also deal with and
people said did you mention the Latino
community and no not because we didn't
care but because we were trying to focus
but again that's another you know it's
either a whole new book or you know an
Edition you know second edition
paperback will add an extra chapter but
there's definitely like these other
groups that definitely deal with the
same issues in America but you know
they're not quote unquote black
Americans which is something you know
it's hard to define and of itself so I
think that was gonna be the end thank
you all so much for coming
Laurie and Agana on behalf of the Penn
community I want to say thank you for
coming out thank you this is very very
interesting and I think you will all
agree with me that this is a very
intriguing book and the authors are
going to join us for a while to find
some coffee so please come up and
purchase the book here at the cash
register and they will sign it